this is a cardinal sin of edm right here
[Music]
dive in and say hey i'm a trans dj and i
can hit one note and put a bass drum on
it and that's my tune
[Music]
this class is just a good primer for
anyone wanting to get
into the production of electronic music
this can all be done correctly
with [ __ ] minimal amount of software
which is why
you can have kid make a dance hit on a
laptop
using an ssl g series compressor on a
dance music kick
makes no sense whatsoever ninety percent
of my time is just
goofing around and trying to come up
with something that's the way i go about
making music because i'm just completely
like
i want my first chord to go there
[Music]
see that's my life right now because if
i could just play it i'd play it but i
can't so i have to
draw it
if you're not naturally comfortable on
stage from my own personal experience
you should try putting on a helmet that
covers your face
so you don't have to see anyone
[Music]
i could teach someone how to get you
know from nothing to something
when you come up with an idea that
you've never actually heard before
or have never heard anyone do that's
something really cool
this class is designed for you to
develop your own style and developing
your own sound
if you can impact one person with your
music then
it is pretty much worth it sometimes it
happens in five years sometimes it
happens in 10 years sometimes it doesn't
happen at all but it's definitely 100
not going to happen if you don't go out
there and
drive yourself
i'm dead mouse and this is my master
[Music]
class
you